this is a special video today we're
talking about a topic that heavily
affects both this channel and in general
all of YouTube as a platform but don't
worry nobody is shutting down this
channel but maybe those of us who watch
from the European Union will no longer
be able to watch some of our videos
yesterday we're talking about article 13
something you might have heard of
especially if you live in Europe because
YouTube seems to have replaced all of my
YouTube ads which were previously would
you love a chocolate bar with something
related to article 13
now let's quickly make one thing clear
here we are definitely biased but that's
probably not a huge surprise to you in
fact we're playing an active role in
this matter one member of the visual
politic team was in Brussels recently
talking about article 13 with policy
makers who are currently negotiating it
that by the way it would be Fonseca also
known as the drunk Spanish guy doing the
voiceovers in some of the earlier
episodes according to some comments to
this day there is no Association
representing European online creators
this is why a group of European YouTube
channels decided to take a bit of an
initiative and show our concerns to the
relevant politicians visual politic we
are one of them so for those who don't
know it article 13 is part of an EU
directive which aims to regulate
copyright online but the question is now
well what exactly is article 13 is it as
terrible as everyone is saying and most
important of all what can we content
creators do about it well today we're
going to answer all of these questions
but before we do as always let's take a
look back at the history
[Applause]
[Music]
for me for the last few years answering
the what do you do for a living question
I kind of got sort of complicated some
people especially maybe the older set
they tend to think well that's nice dear
but you know what do you do for actual
money
some of them I've just given up on I'm
pretty sure that my grandma thinks I'm a
television presenter here in Prague
[Music]
but the answer is yes I make a living
doing this and it's probably not all
that surprising to all of you
Millennials watching now we British we
don't like talking about money
indeed fun fact here we're seven times
more likely to tell someone we've had an
STD than we are to reveal our income to
them but awkwardness and aside let's
just take visual politic both the
English and the Spanish version combines
they get about 10 million views a month
and as you can imagine this translates
in do something you know it's a lot of
people watching now no visual politic it
doesn't make us millionaires but along
with the patreon donations thank you
very much and the ads we can all draw a
decent salary and look we're not the
only ones there aren't thousands of
creators just like us all across Europe
creators with enough of an audience to
make an income and you can create new
jobs
[Music]
and that's only YouTube it also happens
on other platforms like Instagram and
Facebook and twitch
this means that online creators we've
become an industry I mean it's not
exactly oil and gas but it does exist
it's an industry that employs thousands
of people in Europe and creates value
for society most of the time yes YouTube
might be an American company but the
world's biggest youtuber that's
PewDiePie I think hold on yes go
PewDiePie he is still beating t-series
and he's Swedish alright so what exactly
is the problem then well like I said
there is no association that represents
us creators in Europe
[Music]
Media corporations and record labels
they've got trade associations and
they've even got big lobbies in Brussels
windows why well mainly because we
started out little by little the story
behind every youtuber is pretty much the
same you start small make a few videos
hopefully you see a bit of growth and
then suddenly you can be like oh like do
this as a job and as you can imagine
during this process as someone who's
been through this process I haven't and
I imagine most people don't think at any
point hmm now I should create a trade
association you know just in case one
day the European Union is like let's
produce a big old directive that really
affects these people it's just something
that doesn't come across our minds
[Music]
all right so at this point it's probably
important for you to know exactly how
copyright works in Europe well to this
day we're under these so-called
ecommerce directive and also the
copyright directive both of these were
passed back in 2001 so well how does
this legislation work well let's imagine
that I upload a video to visual politic
and I use video clip from a band let's
say I upload a song by the band Tasmania
who often provide music for this channel
but let's assume I upload their song
without permission this means I've
actually created something illegal
Tasmania or the record label who holds
their rights can then sue me this means
that essentially they can request a big
fine from me and do they do it well
probably not I'm a pretty small creator
and my pockets are just not that deep so
well what can Tasmania do well they can
go to YouTube and they can ask them to
take down the video
indeed this process is often mostly
automatic YouTube actually has a tool
the smart filter called Content ID in
this case Tasmania would send all of the
information about their song to YouTube
this way YouTube can scan the platform
looking for that song any time they find
it they can take down the offending
video this is how the law works
and that's all fine and that's all well
and good but just hold on a second
because this is where the interesting
part comes in now Tasmania can pretty
much ask YouTube hey YouTube how about
instead of just taking that video down
you slice me off a bit a sweet sweet or
Evan your pie and send it my way now
according to the letter of the law
YouTube does have to block a song if
requested but the law doesn't say
anything about paying licenses which is
essentially what Tasmania wants
nonetheless since YouTube is apparently
pretty chill they want to do business
with Tasmania so they essentially say
alright then what we'll do is we'll
negotiate a license we'll give you a
little slice and everyone's happy
sounds good in other words they've
negotiated a contract and now you might
be wondering well how big is that slice
of the revenue pie well according to the
record labels it's pretty low just
consider what Paul McCartney
today some user upload content platforms
refused to compensate artists and all
music creators fairly for their work
while they exploit it for their own
profit Sir Paul McCartney the question
now is is Paul McCartney right or wrong
YouTube states they give the majority of
the revenue to the record label but we
don't really know because the labels
want to keep this information
confidential
we also don't know because well we asked
them and nobody would tell us there is
one thing we do know though the European
music associations like I fpy or Impala
they want YouTube to pay more they claim
there is a so-called value gap between
the revenue YouTube generates and what
they pay them in other words they want
to have a stronger negotiation position
and how can they do that well that would
be with a new copyright law that forces
platforms like YouTube to pay a license
this is why in the year 2016 the
European Commission wrote the first
draft for this directive on copyright in
the digital single market
[Applause]
according to this law YouTube and the
rest of the user-generated content
platforms must compensate fairly to
creators
this means that YouTube doesn't give
that and percentage because they're
chill but rather because they're legally
compelled to and this is a big deal this
means that the record labels have a
better negotiating position all right so
so far all of this it doesn't actually
sound that terrible so just hold on a
moment though because this is where
things get really complicated
in devil is in the details as you might
or might not know the European
Commission itself cannot pass a law they
have to send it first to the European
Parliament and then to the European
Council these two institutions they have
to write their own versions of the law
and this is where the real issue with
article 13 comes up
[Music]
online content sharing service providers
perform an act of communication to the
public article 13 paragraph 1
eu-parliament vision alright so now you
might be thinking are I Simon what is up
where exactly is the problem here
alright so to make that clear for you I
really do need to translate what we just
heard from the language of the European
Parliament
it basically means YouTube would have
unlimited liability on the content that
stays on their platform to illustrate
the impact of this let's go back to our
Tasmania banned example now they
couldn't only sue me they could also sue
me and YouTube and remember my mention
of deep pockets well YouTube absolutely
has those other words according to this
legislation YouTube would have to spend
millions in lawsuits just think about it
because there's such a huge quantity of
video going up to YouTube indeed over
300 hours of videos are uploaded every
minute the chances are many of those
videos can have some sort of copyright
violation and YouTube just needs to have
one video with a copyright issue to give
them a potentially multi-million dollar
legal headache now obviously YouTube
cannot deal with that kind of legal
exposure so they have to find a way to
avoid it and how do they do that well
they have to build a wall in this case a
very strict firewall basically any video
with third-party content would have to
be blocked of course if you're in
America you could still watch it because
this law only effects content watched or
uploaded inside Europe so if this law
gets passed well good luck trying to
want videos inside of the European Union
and I'm not just talking about people
who are Platt this really violating
copyright here I'm talking about most
videos because it's really hard to work
out what is and what is not third-party
content in fact it's pretty much almost
impossible basically everything just
beyond a dude talking to a camera with a
white backgrounds would have a risk of
being blocked and well that actually
includes this video because right now
I'm gonna show you a quote from Donald
Trump on CNN Slee I think you should let
me run the country you run CNN or and if
you did it well your ratings let me ask
I know you're gonna say you're probably
thinking well come on Sam you haven't
done anything illegal there I mean
that's got to be fair use right and yes
you're absolutely right according to the
law I can use content in this manner for
satire and illustration but you know
what that YouTube firewall is not a
lawyer it's an algorithm an algorithms
don't understand context or the law so
this brand new YouTube firewall would
just say well third party content block
it and last that and the same goes when
I show you this clip from Tasmania
[Music]
is this illegal no but I think good luck
trying to make a robot understand legal
caveats and really all of my YouTube
created comrades watching this video are
going to agree with me that there are
many problems with the filters on
YouTube already so imagine how tough
it's going to be when there's an even
more aggressive firewall but hold on a
moment because it's not all bad news
there is an alternative indeed there is
a solution it's a solution that makes
everybody moderately happy and that is
actually pretty realistic what can it be
done about this as I told you before
this copyright directive has been voted
on in the European Parliament's but this
doesn't mean the legislation has been
passed in fact we're still in the middle
of it all you see the process to pass an
EU directive it goes as follows first
step the European Commission creates a
first draft that's how we got the first
version of article 13 second step this
draft goes to the EU parliaments they
write another draft and they vote on it
this is why we have another version of
article 13 but now there is a third step
and a third player coming in and that's
the European Council
[Music]
the European Council is where all of the
member states are represented and oh yes
they have approved another version of
article 13 so yes dear viewers we don't
just have one article 30 we actually
have three different versions one from
the Commission one from the Parliament
and one from the council European
political institutions are so simple
said no one ever so well what happens
next well now we are in the third step
which is when the Commission the
Parliament and the council they get
together and they negotiate in Brussels
speak this is called other trial logs
[Music]
and yes that is sort of a dialogue but
with three people like I said things are
never simple in Brussels even the words
they use so let's imagine a big room
with a big round table on the one hand
we have the Commission represents divin
terror advisors on the other we have the
representative of the Parliament and on
the other we have the one from the
Council cousing all of the
representatives and advisers we have
over 30 people negotiating they meet
almost every week and you better believe
me it is a long process which probably
doesn't surprise you in this case we
have three different texts and believe
me the one from the council is very
different
[Music]
in the absence of the authorization an
online content sharing provider shall
not be liable for the act of the
communication to the public when it
demonstrates that it has made its best
efforts and upon notification by rights
holders it has acted Expedia Slee to
remove or disable access to these works
article 13 paragraph 4 all right let me
translate that for you this means that
YouTube is liable for the content on
their platform but that the liability is
mitigated still we might need to clarify
what that means so let's get back to the
Tasmania example with this new law in
hand YouTube must report to them the
songs that are uploaded on the platform
and they have to ask them whether they
want to take the video down or get a
license from it at this moment Tasmania
will have to add their data and metadata
into a form this way that filter YouTube
already has the so-called Content ID
system already knows what to track but
not only that according to this article
13 version if YouTube shows they have
done everything possible to protect the
copyright they cannot be sued
[Music]
in other words if YouTube plays by the
rules they can avoid a lot of legal
uncertainty now yes they would have to
pay more money to the record labels but
there's no existential risk anymore and
of course we their content creators
would also be happy to because we don't
have to worry about all of our videos
being blocked and finally of course the
record labels are happy as well because
they get what they need better
conditions for negotiating
[Music]
so let me quickly summarize for you
what's the difference between the
Parliament and the council positions the
consequences of the parliaments version
is that European YouTube would just
become another TV channel only the
creators who already have a big audience
would survive why because they're the
only ones you can pay a lawyer to manage
all of the copyright issue so that
YouTube will let them upload videos but
there's gonna be a pretty big wall and
it's gonna be pretty impossible to
surpass for the hundreds of thousands of
small creators but there is a way to
find common ground for all of the
players here and of course it's
compromise and compromise that's what
politics is all about so now the big
question is well what comes after this
third step what is the fourth step here
well after this legislation has been
negotiated by the trial logs they bring
it back to the Parliament there they
vote yes or no on the text and then we
go to the final step and this is an EU
directive now a new directive is not
actually a law but it's rather a
guideline so after the directive gets
passed it has to go to all of the Member
States where they turn it international
laws and this is another moment where
online creators have to show up and
speak to their national governments and
yes if you're a European YouTube creator
watching this right now that includes
you so if there's one thing that we
learned from our trip to Brussels its
kind of the policy makers they don't
even know we exist and if they don't
know about us as an industry if they
don't know that thousands of people live
off creating content online they will
not understand how many people might get
unemployed because of a bad regulation
so if you like this video rather than
asking you to subscribe today I'd
suggest that you share it with a friends
a creator a fan of European hopefully
someone who will help make a difference
now at some point in the future we're
probably we're going to need to act on
this and hear a visual politic we're
gonna keep you posted and thank you for
watching and if you've enjoyed hearing
my lovely voice consider checking out
the dreams around the world YouTube
channel for more on travel psychology
and personal development
[Music]